اعلنا اتحاد الموظفين العاملين في وكاله
غوث وتشغيل اللاجئين الفلسطينيين اونور
وفي الضفه الغربيه المحتله عن استئناف
الاضراب الشامل والمفتوحه حيث سيشمل كل
القطاعات التابعه للوكاله في الضفه
الغربيه بدءا من اليوم وقال الاتحاد
ياتي بعد فشل المفاوضات مع اداره الوكاله
بشان الحقوق النقابيه التي يطالب بها
موظفون الوكاله منذ سنوات عده محملا اداره
الاونروا المسؤوليه عن فشل المبادره التي
تقدمت بها السلطه الفلسطينيه ومنظمه
التحرير الفلسطينيه مطلع الشهر الماضي
مدينه رام الله مراسله الجزيره سمير
بوشماله سمير اجمل تطورات الساعات الاخيره
وماذا يعني استئناف اضراب العمال الامور
يعني ميدانيا نبدا بالاعتقالات التي سنتها
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه في بلده قباطيه
في جنين وايضا في الفوار في الخليل هناك
كان اعتقال الاثنين من الفلسطينيين خلال
عمليات دهن هاتين البلدين وسط مواجهات
اندلعت مع قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه
يتركزت هذه الاعتقالات باعتقال والد
الشهيد محمود اكميل الذي استشهد عند باب
حطها في البلده القديمه في القدس المحتله
في نهايه عام 2020 وايضا اعتقلت هذا
الوالد ولكن لم تتوضح اسباب اعتقاله
ونقلته الى مراكز التوقيف للتحقيق معه
وايضا كان هناك اعتقال لاحد المصابين في
مخيم الفوار في الخليل خلال دهن هذا
المخيم هذه الاعتقالات جاءت ايضا قبل بعد
ساعات من بعد المناوشات والصدمات المحدوده
التي وقعت بين شبان الفلسطينيين وايضا
القوات الاحتلال في عدد من القرى والبلدات
الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه وايضا مهاجمه
المستوطنين لعدد من القرى وتحديدا في قريه
بورين الجنوبيه مدينه نابلس هذا على
المستوى الميداني هناك ايضا على المستوى
المتعلق بوكاله وتشغيل اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين هناك استئناف او اصدار بيان
من قبل الاتحاد العام للعاملين العرب في
وكاله غوت وتشغيل اللاجئين الفلسطينيين
الاونروا والاستئناف الاضراب الذي تجمد
وتم تعليقهم قبل نحو اسبوعين او او ثلاث
اسابيع على الاقل بعد ان تدخلت وساطات من
قبل وزاره العمل الفلسطينيه وايضا منظمه
التحرير الفلسطينيه والتحديدا دائره شؤون
اللاجئين فيها وذلك لبدء حوار جديد مع
وكاله الغرب او مع الاداره العامه للوكاله
ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه لم تسفر هذه
لم يسفر هذا الحوار عن اي تطورات او اي
يعني اشياء ايجابيه للموظفين الذين
يطالبون مطالب نقابيه تتعلق برفع الاجور
الاجور وايضا العلاوات التي تم يتم
مطالبتها منذ نحو 2008
للوكاله ولتحسين ظروفهم المعيشيه وخاصه ان
مستويات الاجور لديهم لم تتغير منذ نحو
خمسه عشر عاما نحن الان نقف عند مخيم
الجلزون وهو واحد من تسعه عشر مخيما تعطلت
فيه الخدمات التعليميه والصحيه
والاجتماعيه من قبل وكلاء وكاله الغوص
الدوليه وذلك بسبب هذا الاضراب الذي تسبب
في حرمان نحو مليون لاجئ فلسطيني في هذه
المخيمات من هذه الخدمات ايضا المدارس
التابعه للوكاله الغوث الدوليه والتي يبلغ
عددها نحو 96 مدرسه في الضفه الغربيه بما
في ذلك شرقي القدس هي ايضا تعط الحياه
التعليميه فيها وقد تعطلت وجود نحو خمسين
الف طالب وطالبه في هذه المدارس في هذا
التوقيت بالتحديد الذي في هذه السعاده
الصباح والذي من المفترض ان يكون هناك
طلبه وهذا يتعلق بالاضراب للعاملين الذين
يسعون لتلبيه احتياجاتهم ومطالبهم
المعيشيه وايضا تحسين اجورهم ولكن وكاله
الغوث بالمقابل تقول بانها هي تعيش حاله
او ازمه اقتصاديه وماليه صعبه ومعقده جدا
حتى حيث انهات العام الماضي باستدانه 75
مليون دولار لايضا لترتيب اوضاعه الماليه
مع بدايه هذا العام وبالتالي هناك ايضا
تراجع للدعم العربي الذي تحدثنا مع الناطق
باسم الوكاله الغاوت وتتحدث بان هناك
تراجع للدعم العربي بنسبه 90 في المئه منذ
عام 2018 وهذا يعطل الحياه
في داخل هذه المؤسسه الدوليه وتقديم
الخدمات بشكل اللائق
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين اضافه الى هذا
الاضراب الذي يعطل هذه الحياه
سمير ابو شماله مراسلنا من مخيم الجلزون
شمالي مدينه رام الله